how to become an academic weapon in 2024
except you are not gonna see me inverted
My qualifications
I'm an only child who depends on academic validation
and Asian
next if you say studying is boring
yeah obviously if it wasn't boring
we'd all be geniuses by now
listen to classical music like jazz
lo fi etcetera
don't listen to words and lyrics cause I know you're gonna get distracted
or you can listen to brown noise and noise cancelling headphones
have like an aesthetic study space
stick up motivational quotes if you need to
make a laptop aesthetic and get cute stationery candles
have snacks with you like frozen grapes or tea
go to a cafe or library or search up like Cafe ASMR if you want the ambience
get inspo from Pinterest or pretend to be Rory Gilmore
get inspo from how rich you're gonna get once you finish school
here's a little motivational board for you
next supplies
a 30 centimeter foldable ruler so you can actually roll your margins properly
get a whiteboard
it makes everything so much more fun
just trust me on this one
mechanical pencils
so you're not always going to the bin to sharpen your pencils mild liners
I love these
they're so cute and aesthetic oogie pens
thanks no taking
don't waste your time on making them aesthetic
cause like how often do you read them anyway
spend more time on studying than note taking
you can use the Cornell Notes method
this is what it looks like
Apps and websites
Study Bunny it's like a timer app for studying and it gets you off your phone
great app for flashcards
and quizzing yourself and revising
quizlet please sponsor me
Khan Academy teaches you math and there's like practice problems and stuff
we all know notion by now
notion please sponsor me
Nox Ocean same concept as Study Bunny
except instead of feeding a bunny
you build like underwater buildings
Flora same thing except it's flowers
photomath doing maths problems with your camera
study stream
where you can like hop on a zoom
meeting with other people and like study together
Sigma OS it's like a browser which lets you like organise your tabs
and you can go on YouTube without seeing ads
spark notes so you all know spark notes
like English notes and stuff Simbo Lab
a maths calculator and you can do graphing on it
study Youtubers No. 1
amoeba sister's biology
Eddie Woo for maths
the organic chemistry tutor for chemistry
oversimplified for history
Khan Academy for maths
Nancy Pi for maths
she needs to come back
I don't know where she went
um Ruby Granger
studytuber faye films
studytuber Mike Dee
Productivity
Elizabeth Phillips
Productivity Merve
study with me videos
techniques flashcards
digital or physical
past papers and exams
active recall
where you like force yourself to recite things from memory
just like 10 minutes for each subject
each someone or pretend
Pomodoro method
where you work for 25 minutes and you rest for five minutes
or you work for 50 minutes and rest for five minutes
for example if you're thinking of ribosomes
it's protein synthesis
and ribosomes sounds like ribs
ribs is meat
meat gives you protein
go on a walk with your flashcards until you memorize all of them
that's what I did when I used to do Italian
and I had to memorize my oral in like a day
practice essays
chew a specific flavour of gum when you study
so your brain knows to study when you chew the gum
um same thing
but with a candle
and then having a playlist for each subject
I've got some playlist in my bio
if you wanna listen to them
power down your phone and shove it in a drawer somewhere
think about everyone that is better than you
that's my No. 1 motivation
pretend you're a scientist who's about to make a breakthrough
reward yourself
have like a little snack or go shopping or something after you do on a test
and if you're really desperate
wake up at 5:00am
which is what I do sometimes
and then that way I'm like more productive in the morning
I don't know
thanks for listening to my Ted talk